hallo mein Name ist willkommen meine
Damen und Herren ich darf euch heute
recht herzlich willkommen heißen zu der
nächsten Folge mit Luca in meinem
letzten TV Video wurde ich ja gebannt
sie wurden vom chatverband Grund
irrelevantes Bild ich bin für
Stunden gebannt oder ich bezahle um den
Bann auf
allerdings hat euer reicher Youtuber
natürlich die 10 € Strafe bezahlt
danke und natürlich hat sich der Laser
auch fürs heutige Video nicht lumpen
lassen und eine richtig coole Idee am
Start gebracht denn ich werde heute so
tun als wäre ich ein Standbild
und dann hoffe ich dass die Leute das
nicht merken
ich dachte
endlich
okay
ich musste so lachen verdammt die Nacht
aber ich schlafe aber ich muss ja meine
Augen geschlossen halten weil wenn ich
dir geöffnet hätte dann kann ich länger
als 10 20 Sekunden also tun als welchen
Standbild ohne zu zwinkern jetzt tue ich
allerdings mal so als würde ich hier im
Schrank hinter mir gerade was suchen
hallo
ist dir was ich Trottel nicht bedacht
habe der Smiley dreht sich ja ich bin
der größte Idiot mit meiner Situation
ist der dauerhaft rot und diese Flasche
jetzt dauerhaft grün und auch ganz kurz
zur Info noch mal für euch sieht es zwar
gerade so aus ne wie das ich halt
eingeblendet ist für die Leute die mich
sehen sie da allerdings so aus also ich
habe eine zweite Kamera hier am Start
hallo ich tue jetzt mal so als würde ich
meinen Kopf wieder aufstützen und
nebenan auf den anderen Bildschirm
schauen
[Musik]
durch den Witz erzählen
ich will den Witz erzählen
das kann ich schwimmen und hat einen Arm
ein Kran
und was kann ich schwimmen und das Brot
ein roter Kran
warum lachst du nicht
ich will dich voll gemobbt
die Frage ist ab wann löse ich denn dann
auf meine Videos ein bisschen mehr
Gedanken machen jetzt tue ich allerdings
mal so als wäre ich gar nicht im Bild
schauen wir mal wie die Leute reagieren
[Musik]
Leute am Stück weggedrückt
viermal am Stück
die können sich in meinem Stuhl
unterhalten
das kann normalerweise nur ich wenn ich
in die Toilette schaue
scheiß drauf ist lustig weil das ist ja
ein Stück egal
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob mein aufnahmezimmer so
wenig Wiedererkennungswert hat dass
jeder sich einfach nur denkt das ist
irgendein Trottel aber hallo ich bin
Laser Luca danke
[Musik]
es reicht schon wieder weggedrückt
worden man muss immer
so weiter mit dem eigentlichen Thema des
heutigen Videos ich tue so als wäre ich
ein Standbild
ich mache jetzt mal genauso und schau
wie lange ich das halten kann
hallo
ist echt ich habe reingeschissen ich
wollte zu tun als wäre ich ein Standbild
ich habe aber verkackt weil ich musste
blinzeln
bist du echt nee dicker bin ich nicht
oha
angekommen
[Musik]
200.000 Leute online TV nee was spielst
du Fußball
[Musik]
trifft da sind Väter dabei mit ihren
Kindern da sind rauchende Jugendliche
vom Pausenhof mit dabei das sind Leute
auf dem Trecker mit dabei irgendwelche
Jungs die Volleyball spielen im Verein
ja okay am Strand in der Sonne ok aber
diesen Hallenboden voll die Ball das
haben wir in jeder
sportunterrichtsstunde gespielt das ist
doch so ein kacksport allerdings
Standbild probieren
alles gut
[Musik]
okay
es ist das allererste Mal dass Leute
Angst vor mir hatten
[Musik]
hallo
mein Gott
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
Pepsi Becher in deinem Regal stehen
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
ja klar
das heutige Video auch beenden meine
lieben Freunde wenn euch mal wieder mit
TV mit Luca hier gefallen hat dann einen
Daumen hoch unter dem Video hier da
abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke weitere Videos nicht zu
verpassen schreibt mir zu dem bitte
bitte bitte gerne mal unten in die
Kommentare was ich im nächsten Moment TV
Video machen soll und ich hoffe jetzt
einfach nur dass ich nicht wieder
gesperrt werde und wieder 10 € bezahlen